The general Hogan experience. Now, Donald Trump has 74.
He's overweight needs cheeseburgers every day.
When a guy like that catches COVID and is fine in four
days, people get very dismissive of it,
unfortunately. Right. What did he receive?
What kind of treatment did he receive and how different is it than what the
average person would receive if they got sick?
So he, he faced a very significant risk of death and I think he got lucky.
Um, so remember his doctors put them on dexamethazone. So,
so far we only have one proven drug, uh, that lowers your risk of death.
If you're seriously ill from COVID.
And that's a very simple steroid called dexamethazone and, um,
Ramdev severe has not been shown to lower mortality. Um,
it has been shown to lower your length of hospital stay.
So there's some benefit to it,
but it doesn't appear to lower your risk of death.
And the difference between lowering your risk of hospital,
stay and lowering your risk of death.
Why would they let you out of the hospital if you hadn't shown significant
health improvements and wouldn't significant health improvements when
significant health improvements, SIG signify that your body's recovering better.
Yeah, it's a mystery and it's confusing.
And when the first room desk of your trial was published a few months ago,
it didn't show a benefit for mortality, but it showed, but it showed a trend.
It looked like it would help. And it made sense.
Like if it's lowering your hospital duration, probably it's good for you.
And it'll also lower your risk of death,
but then another trial came out much bigger trial as part of the, um,
think it was called the solidarity consortium,
either the solidarity or the recovery. I can't remember right now,
consortium out of England, which show that actually roomed us of your head,
no benefit for, um, mortality. Now, how can that be? Imagine that,
imagine that, uh,
you have a hundred people who are sick and in the group that gets from this
severe, uh,
they only wind up Spain spending an average of 10 days in the hospital, but, um,
10 of the people die. And in the other study, uh,
the people that did not get REM death severe,
a a hundred people get sick and they spend an average of 12 days in the
hospital, but again, 10 of them die.
So the rum death severe has lowered the hospital duration from 12 to 10 days,
but it hasn't affected the probability of people dying that's entirely possible.
And that is in fact what appears to have. Yeah.
And this was a study you said that was in England.
Yes. It was a large study. That was, I think,
I think the subjects were not just in England.
It was organized by a group of English scientists,
either the solidarity or the recovery consortium.
And I just don't remember right now the name of it, but,
but I want to go back to your question about the president.
So the president was given dexamethazone and when that happened,
I stated publicly that either the president was
sicker than they were telling us.
So he was sufficiently sick that they wanted to give him because giving
dexamethazone early in the course of the disease before you're very sick,
actually can harm you.
So you don't want to give it to someone at the beginning of their disease.
You need to wait until they're sufficiently sick, and then it helps you.
So either he was sicker than they told us.
And so they were lying to us or he was, uh,
really needed the dexamethazone.
In which case he faced a significant risk of death.
So people in the trials that show that the dexamethazone worked
74 year old overweight people,
men and men are much greater risk of dying than women of this condition who
got the dexamethazone. They had about a 20% chance of death.
So I think the president actually faced a 20% chance of death when he was at the
hospital, which is a big risk of death. And I think he, he got lucky. He,
you know, he survived. He was also given the, this cocktail of, of, um,
artificial antibodies to the disease,
which I think is another promising approach to treating this condition.
We don't yet have the results of those randomized controlled trials,
but we'll also know soon if those drugs.
So this was an experimental treatment that they gave him.
Yes. They gave him not the dexamethazone. That was a well-documented treatment.
But the antibody antibody cocktail was apparently the CEO of the company
of Regeneron was his golfing buddy or something. I'm not exactly sure.
So whatever it was, it seemed to be very effective.
And then immediately that he went on a wild tweet storm.
It seemed like he had a lot of energy.
Well, the dexamethazone may have given him a steroid high.
I wouldn't conclude that the antibody cocktail was necessarily effective.
We don't know.
I didn't, I didn't mean that I meant all the treatment, the overall treatment,
whatever they gave him when he was in the hospital,
the response was for a 74 year old guy to be back on the campaign trail with
this rigorous campaign that he was doing four or five days later.
Yes, yes. I did not expect that at all. And, uh, and I,
as I said, I think he got lucky and I do think, you know, steroids can give you,
um, can make you a little psychotic and a little manic actually. And I,
and I think, I mean, you know, you can't really know from a distance, but to me,
he had, uh, as a doctor, I looking at him,
I thought this man has a little bit of a manic feel to him, but then, you know,
even that went.
Away just from the Twitter feed.
Yeah. I mean, isn't, that is how we always is. Well,
I'm not an expert on Donald Trump's tweets,
but if you just looked at some of the things you're right.
Maybe he was always that way. But if you look at, if you look at
some of the things he did, like, I think the,
that little having the secret service drive him around the hospital was a bit,
you know, it was a bit manic, you know,
that was like a very irresponsible thing to do would expose people to risk it,
put his own health at risk. I mean, you and I,
if you and I were in the hospital with COVID and we told our, our doctors,
you know, I just want to, for a drive around the block right now, let me,
I mean, they would, they would say no, you know, uh,
that would not be an okay thing to do. I wanted to wave to people, right? Yes.
Yeah. Hilarious.
Episodes of the Joe Rogan experience are now free on Spotify. That's right.
They're free from September 1st is September 1st.
They're going to be available everywhere, but after December 1st,
they will only be available on Spotify, but they will be free.
That includes the video. The video will also be there. It'll also be free.
That's all we're asking you just go download Spotify much. Buh-bye.